I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense transition is powerful it's
scary
mm-hm it's uncomfortable mm-hmm and just
what I've noticed is being able to
communicate about it us being a little
late it's like we're going through our
ships it's like okay that feels good
but then communicating with our partners
and people who were within life also
said they understand that's definitely
was a problem that I had in wasn't
exactly what wasn't communicating to him
I just I buried like everything that I
was feeling and I was burying it for
myself to not not just from him or
anyone I was like I didn't like you said
I didn't want to go there so I just
buried and buried of course it's of
course disconnection now yes and I mean
to like own up to my own stuff I really
see that yeah I had lost myself on how
to cope right because it's like not it's
not easy to take it all on yourself so
when it's a transition time for me you
almost have to go you you you have to
you I mean I'm not great at meditating I
feel like there's there's opportunity
there for understanding I'm not created
it I'm more of a writer Walker
yeah talker thinker I would like to
expand more into that into meditation
because it's so powerful according to
anyone who does it regularly but you
know when I'm in a time of transition
look like I call upon my girlfriends I
call upon you others family whoever you
really trust and can be vulnerable with
they come into the picture writing and
journaling comes into the picture
spending some time some quiet time alone
stop with the distractions stop with the
stuff that pulls you away stop with the
egoic things that pull you away from
what your soul is asking you to face
it's easy right you can pick up your
phone you can go to do it make a dinner
date you can drink you can
right I mean all of these things are
going to take you away from your
ultimate goal so in a time of transition
when you're starting to feel something
feel something weird I'm trying to put
it into words like if you haven't dealt
with some something like this but like
if you just kind of feel not right or
not on or not like syncing up with your
partner or even your job like when you
just feel out of sync that can be or
your signal to face something that
you're about to transition through yep
and rings true my recommendation like
like they always say with spirituality
great like spiritual growth I feel like
there's funny funny pictures on
Instagram of what we think spiritual
growth looks like and what it actually
looks like and it's like yeah unicorns
and rainbows and [ __ ] like this is what
it looks like yoga meditation the beach
I Mustang but what does it really look
like what does spiritual growth really
look like it looks like I'm crying a box
of Kleenex [ __ ] mess like I mean just
like going through the [ __ ] yep and it
it it isn't pretty but here's the other
thing about spiritual growth is that
once it started for me and so for me I
guess it was like it was really when we
started our girls trips in 2013 so that
was probably the really like the big
start of it all and then probably really
in 2015 on our little Sedona trip that
was probably like the next level of it
so it's been you know in that sort of 4
to 6 range 4 to 6 year range of
transition but but it's like it's
nothing you can quit once you start yeah
you never turn back no and I don't know
anyone that started on a spiritual
journey of the journey to the self the
his turn back
I don't either I think that's there's
religious people that turn away you can
be in a religion and turn away because
again in my opinion it's not about the
self
it's about outward like oh you know what
can you do for I mean like doing things
for others is great but when you really
turn the mirror around on yourself and
look
so why did you react like that where is
that coming from what do you need to
face where do you need to grow it's not
someone else's fault if you just start
assuming that the what what is happening
in your life is your fault now that's
the bad word is your responsibility to
understand mm-hmm you grow period and
you'll transition and then you'll end up
on the other side it's gonna come again
though and that's the that's the fun
part is that it's about the process it
is
[Music]